marlon wayans remembers the late Charlie
Murphy I'm sad and you know hurt by his
departure all my love goes to Eddie and
his kids and the entire family
eg caught up with Marlon add YouTube
space la for an upcoming project with
NBC where he paid tribute to the
comedian is there any fond memory that
you have of him since he was such a
comedic legend Oh plenty man I mean you
know I've known Charlie since I was 9
Eddie Murphy came to my house and my
brother came really good friends and I
used to hear stories about Charlie and
then I met him he looked like me and
Eddie and you know and we sees him call
him me and Eddie and you know he was a
guy he looked like you under kick us in
the chin but he's always sweet people
always X is there a rivalry between you
and Eddie yes there is we always going
back and forth trying to figure out who
has the biggest nose and I remember when
I started doing stand-up
Charlie would come out to the Caroline's
and you you know he came to see me
performing but you real funny man I like
what you're doing he gets real funny and
he would give me a you know good
encouragement you know comedy is like a
community man were all brothers and then
we lose one we lost him when we lost
records and I was a tough month so but I
know that they're making God laughs and
here's the thing about you know Charlie
being the youngest brother is very hard
you know it was always hard being
Eddie's brother there's the biggest
movie star in the world that had to be
hard but what I'm happy about is he
worked hard he found his Lane he did his
Chappelle show
he did his comedy and when he died he
was Charlie Murphy and so I think God
wrote him a beautiful song and may he
rest well and just know that you
accomplished something while you're here
and he made you walk the world